everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comte they're gonna be going
over an extended line in the cobweb Khan
and it's the fantasy variation so starts
out with Pawnee for c6 pawn here to d4
and then pawn d5 this is the Cour Khan
and the fantasy variation that we're
gonna be going over is pawn here to f3
it's pretty exciting it does have you
know weakness for white along this g1
here to a7
so the the dark square bishop for black
could definitely be a factor you know
dark square Bishop would like to be here
and you know let's say c5 or b6 and kind
of hone down on that weakness for white
so why it definitely has to you know
keep in mind that that's there also is
blocking off this knight here to f3 so
if this pawn would move away that would
be fantastic for white or we could
always play something like Knight here
to e2 or even a knight here to h3 and
then move it back here to f2 and try to
help control this pawn here on e4 but a
lot of the different versions that black
can kind of go into we can always play
the solid pawn here to e6 looking
forward to later on playing you know
pawn here to g6 being kiddo on the
kingside maybe later on play something
like pawn here it's a c5 trying to
stretch the Queen side and kind of
attack those those dark squares so after
the trade off you know the Queen or the
bishop we can come down here to c5 as we
talked about really attack that weakness
that white has right here you also may
see black just take right here on the e4
this is pretty common white has you know
two responses you can always take back
with this pawn you can always play
something like Knight heater c3 so we're
gonna in this video kind of talk about
some of the main lines that you'll sees
some of the key concepts and really how
to attack against the car con with the
fantasy variation and the first line we
are going to talk about is when D
captures here on e4 now as we just
discussed White has two different
options the first time we're going to go
over is if the pawn takes here on e4
this is probably the most common that
you should play it's a little more solid
and black has a lot of different ways to
fall into many different traps so if
we're
go on off of a recommended I I think
this plays very well it also allows you
to you know play night here to f3 later
on not worrying about this you know pawn
on f3 staying there as we'll talk to you
later on you always could play Knight to
c3 hoping that they play kind of this
pawn to f3 and then you know if you do
end up with you know Knight here to f3
this is fine but a lot of times after
you know this move your opponent doesn't
end up taking here on f3 so always solid
if white just takes here on e4 black
really has limited number of moves that
he can do here we're gonna kind of go
over some of the the most common ones he
really should play something like pawn
here to e5 striking the center of the
board white can't just capture here on
e5 and why it's not really too concerned
about the Queen coming down here to d1
and then you know black recapturing
because you know after the Queen comes
off the board why it's not too worried
about his King not being able to Castle
what White's more concerned about is the
Queen coming here to h4 checking and
then this is just a whole lot of bad
news doesn't really matter if the pawn
comes here to g3 to stop it or if the
King comes up and moves you know ii ii
ii or even d to the queen can just come
here to e4 and that's definitely gonna
be bad news for white so instead white
cannot recapture instead white's going
to play right here on f3 again he really
wants to get his not involved into the
game great square for that now i can get
his LightSquared bishop he can castle on
the kingside he has the semi open file
for his rook once he can get it here to
F 1 so this knight move on f3 is really
the only option it gives white so many
different lines that he can attack with
so if we kind of look at this black has
a few options from here the first one
that we may see is pawn takes here on d4
trying to kind of just break up the
center of the board that white has you
know he's really dominating with both
this D in his pawn right here
white could recapture you know he does
have you know a defender with his Knight
here on F 3 but
that's not White's goal here his goal is
to set up a monster attack and so we
have Bishop coming here to c4 and really
this is the best move it really allows
your opponent to hang himself there's so
many different ways that black can get
in trouble if kind of look at it you
know what are the most common moves that
you may see you know from black right
here one of them would be you know
Bishop coming to g4 and so this seems
pretty standard you see from a lot of
players getting a LightSquared bishop
involved into the game pinning down this
knight right here but the bishop can now
just come to f7 check and then after the
King comes here to f7 the knight here to
e5 check and there's a discovered attack
on the bishop here on g4 now the King
doesn't have to take but even after you
know the King comes here to e7 then you
know we have the bishop coming here
taking on d8 and now black can't even
respond with taking with his rook
because if he takes with his rook then
the bishop we can come here to g5 check
and the Queen's going to fall so this is
just all sorts of bad news for black if
we kind of look at it so the bishop here
to g4 definitely that's gonna be a trap
another movie that you may see is you
know the bishop coming here to c5 trying
to control this c5 pawn right here and
again this is this is gonna be
completely fine why it's not too worried
about all the material right away he's
really just trying to launch a solid
attack right now so you know why can
just respond by castling on the King
side you know later on he can you know
if the knight comes here to f6 then we
can see something like Knight here to g5
and this really opens up the door for
this you know semi open file for the
rook right here you know next move you
can see something like pawn here to e5
again there's now an attack both the
bishop and the knight here are both
attacking the pawn here on f7 so many
different ways that the white can really
attack right now and black is just kind
of sitting there trying to figure out
okay yeah he's got a bishop that's
attacking or you know protecting this
pawn but he's just not doing too much
beyond that next version we're gonna go
over is let's say the pawn doesn't take
here on d4 but instead the bishop first
comes here to g4 why it's immediately
gonna play Bishop to c4 just as before
lay in the trap you know if the pawn
comes here to d4 right away looking you
know to take your on f7 same kind of
setup as before if the pawn doesn't take
could play something like Knight here to
f6 still gonna swing in for the trap
here Bishop takes on f7 same kind of
thing if the King takes we're gonna play
Knight here to e5 discovered attack not
gonna take with the queen since the
Knights right here but the knight can
take here on g4 if he wants to and then
the Queen can swoop in and recapture
depending on what black does why could
always castle on the King side as well
which would open up the door for a check
as well so that's one option
but if the King doesn't take let's say
you plays King here to e7 it's gonna be
a little bit different because the
bishop is not gonna come to g8 there's
no night for it to take instead the
bishop is going to come back here to b3
and this is super important because this
Bishop is just gonna be a pain in the
side of black he doesn't have his D pawn
which really would block this off and
since his pawn on the e-file you know if
he played it here on e6 this would kind
of stop it but since he's kind of pushed
it up to e5 that's gonna be very good
because there's really no way for blacks
to really stop all this pressure that
you know White has here on b3
so what's black really gonna do here
White has all of his pieces his black
King right here on e7 is not gonna be
safe the rest of the game and why it's
just gonna continue to put a lot of
pressure on black black could fall for
another trap it could play something
like that you know Knight takes on e4
and then Queen here to e2 just putting
too much pressure if this Knight moves
the Queen can just come here to e5
capture and then it's you know check
also the bishop could come here to g5
checking the King pinning it's being
pinned down to the Queen right here at
the 8th and again even if the the knight
moves and takes on on g5 the Queen could
come here and take on e5 y could also
castle on the King side again just
having this entire open file
his rook to dominate on the F file is
really tough to deal with if we come
back if black doesn't make a mistake
because Knight to f6 would be a mistake
you could play something like Knight
here to d7 y is just gonna cast on the
Kings side again this is gonna be good
for him he can get his dark squared
Bishop involved into the game now if he
wants to play something like Knight to
c3
he's just putting a ton of pressure on
black black has at least three more
moves before he can castle on the King
side it's a little bit too unsafe to
castle on the Queen side right now
so y can still again add a ton of
pressure to the game there's a lot of
other options that black has you know it
could try something like Queen to be 7
or B 6 this is gonna be a mistake
because again Bishop can just swing in
here to f7 check again there's nothing
good that's gonna come of this from from
black could also see something like the
bishop coming here to b4 but it's just
not gonna stop a lot you know just pawn
here to c3 just kind of stops that then
the bishop moves back and then really
just white gained another move in the
game and so that's not really what black
wants to do so this is not gonna be good
for black anyway you look at it the next
paper we're gonna look at is let's say
the pawn doesn't come to e5 which is the
most common let's say something like
Knight to f6 again if we're kind of
looking at all the different moves that
black could play doesn't have too many
but Knight to f6 seems pretty common
wifes immediately just gonna play a pawn
to e5 not too many great squares
you know from black that he could really
play if you play something like Knights
here to e4 y can just continue his
development just pretend like this
Knights not even there because it's not
really posing any huge threats right now
if he plays you know kind of the more
common move of Knight here to d5 since
it is kind of protected a nice little
outpost right here y can just continue
to put pressure so something like pawn
here to see for the Knights not really
gonna go anywhere now you know c7 is
pretty bad kind of blocking off not
really doing a whole heck of a lot
something like Knight here to b6 it's
still pretty passive and then you have
you know Knight here to f3 White's just
controlling the center of the board
his pieces a little more clearly defined
as far as what they're doing it's not
really clear how blacks going to respond
in this situation so again definitely
gonna be good for white in this case if
instead something else you may see you
may see Knight here to d7 which is fine
y can just respond with Knight here to
f3 again there's just not a lot of good
moves for black he's gonna have a really
cramped game from here you know it could
try something like g6 trying to fee and
keto on the kingside y can immediately
just come here to Bishop here to see for
game this is a critical Square since
this D pawn is gone you know bringing
your Bishop here to c4 is gonna pose a
lot of threats on your opponent after
you know Bishop here to g7 you know why
can castle on the King side again blacks
just not really stopping anything that
White's doing why it's gonna have a very
very good game from here again as we
said earlier white doesn't have to take
here on e4 and said he could play
something like Knight to c3 kind of
baiting his opponent to play tonight or
pawn takes here on f3 why would really
like this situation right here he's
controlling the stern of the board he
has both of his minor pieces involvement
of the game you know his opponent
doesn't have to take you'd always play
something like Knight here to f6 doesn't
really matter why it's gonna take here
on e4 we kind of have this looking setup
which is a little bit different but you
know next y can look to play something
like Knight to f3 then get as Bishop
here to see for a lot of same
fundamentals as before except the night
starts here on c3 we're gonna talk a lot
of though if the pawn does take on f3
and then you know the knight could
recapture here on f3 some of the things
you may see one would be you know Knight
to f6 right here again pretty common why
it's immediately gonna play Bishop here
to c4 and then look to castle on the
King side so you know is attacking this
f7 pawn you could see you know e6 and
then cancelling on the King side this is
pretty common for white another option
you may see from black is to fianchetto
on the King side so trying to seen this
pawn here on d4 that's really only the
mid pawn that the white has and so
trying to counter-attack hyper-modern
defense trying to control the
the center with his minor pieces and
fianchetto with his bishop here to g7
and again attacking those dark squares
that whites trying to control right now
White's just gonna play Bishop either
c-4 pretty constant theme this pretty
easy variation to understand because
white is gonna be doing the same thing
over and over it's very important as far
as you know that the next few moves
you know if Bishop here to g7 then you
could play you know Bishop here to g5
putting more and more pressure both of
these bishops as bishop pair it's
putting a lot of pressure so this pawn
no longer can move here on e7 if we have
you know Knight coming to f6 the Knight
to e5 is really really dangerous for
black as far as you know why can castle
on the King decide if he wants to you
know why it's putting pressure on this
pawn on f7 so if black wants to stop it
one move he could try is you know black
comes to e6 but then after the exchange
right here white castles on the King
side very very good position for white
if instead the pawn comes up here
instead of you know Bishop to e6 you
have the pawn coming here to e6 then the
rook can swing over here to f1 doesn't
even have to castle on the King side if
he doesn't want to because the Queen can
get involved later and then castle on
the Queen side if you wants to so this
is going to be very good for white as
well now if we come back over here and
instead of the bishop coming to g7 first
if we see something like Knight here to
f6 this would kind of be more of a
mistake but now you can see the knight
coming here to e5 right away again both
attacking the pawn right here and then
we could see you know the bishop take
and then castle on the King side this is
going to be a little bit better for
white because the bishop is not here
right away and then again if we come
back and same kind of thing if the pawn
comes here to e6 right away then the
brooken swing over and then now when the
bishop comes over to g7 to try to
protect this knight he
[ __ ] move whereas before his bishop
was already here on g7 he's kind of down
a move and then it's just a matter of
everyone putting all their pieces trying
to defend this night here on f6 and so
you know if the King castles on the
Kings side then we have the Queen come
over here to f3 and there's just too
much pressure on this night right here
on f6 and again now why can castle on
the Queen side get his other rook
involved and just storm his pawns up on
the King side there's really nothing
good that black can really do it's gonna
be very hard to get his other Knight
involved into the game his other rook is
just gonna be sitting there the rest of
the game and again his LightSquared
Bishop is now blocked off because this
pawn on e6 is kind of blocking it so all
of these are are gonna be very very good
for white the last variation we're gonna
go over is probably one of black's
more solid lines and it's if he plays
pawn here to e6 and it kind of has that
Slav feel if you're familiar with the
Slav offense you know with your pawns
here you know c6 d v & e6 right here
it's it's more of a passive defense it's
not really committing thing right away
it does also take away some of White's
attacking you know white really wants to
play something like Bishop here - z4
that's completely blocked off so this is
why again this is one of more of the
solid ways to defend against the fantasy
variation White's now going to respond
with Knight to c3 which isn't super
common but again this pawn here on f3 is
kind of stopping the knight to come
right here and so he really wishes that
the palm would take but you know the
pawn on e6 now it's gonna be more of a
slower game there's not gonna be any
crazy tactical lines as we talked about
before a few different ways that you
know black can respond if he takes now
with this pawn this is going to be
completely fine white looks to retake
horrible position for black actually
giving up the the D pawn here and then
just having a pawn on c6 and a 6 and
white really controls the center of the
board you don't see that too often you
may sometimes see you know the bishop
coming down here to b4 trying to pin
down the knight to the King right here
you could now just play
- e - again protecting this night you
may not want to play your bishop here -
D - blocking out the Queen because you
may want to get your queen somewhere -
like d3 if you want to but the Knights
again not going to be doing too much
with the pawn here on f3 so this is
going to be completely fine again you
could see something like Knight here to
f3 you could just swing up your Queen
here to d3 gonna be completely fine
again adding another defender on that
this pawn here on e4 that's gonna be
fine if we come back instead of you know
the bishop coming down here to be for
something else you could see is you know
Knight to f6 immediately gonna be met by
pawn here - e5 and then you know there's
no great square for this night because
it becomes back that's obviously gonna
be horrible he just lost an entire move
and white controls the board even more
he plays you know d7 why could solidify
with pawn here to f4 later on just play
Knight to f3 and then really just try to
cramp black style it could also play
something you know Knight here to h5
that's gonna be fine why it's not really
too worried about there's there's nothin
black and really do so well I can just
continue you know bish appeared at u3
get his queen involvement at the game
castle on the Queen side it's not really
moving his other pieces too much there's
no great square for his Bishop right
away so castling on the Queen side looks
a lot better for white in this position
some horrible moves that you may see
from black after you know pawn here to
e6 and then immediately night here c3
you could see something like pawn here
to c5 again it makes somewhat sense
because eventually black would want to
play something like c5 but it's probably
a little bit too soon the pawn can take
here on d5 and then after this the pawn
recaptures on c5 and now White has both
a knight and the Queen looking down at
this pawn here on d5 and why it's gonna
go up in material because even after you
know the bishop comes you know why it's
just gonna be up the material because
the Queen can just immediately take here
on d5 so that's definitely gonna be a
bad move not what black really wants to
be doing although later on once he
develops a little bit more he would try
to play
something like you know pawn here to b5
and try to extend on the queenside since
he's gonna have a pretty safe keen side
after it gets his dark squared Bishop
and his knight involved into the game
last thing you may see is you know Queen
here to b6 putting pressure not only on
this pawn on d4 but also this pawn them
before or this pawn b2 so if you know
the bishop goes anywhere you know could
immediately just come down and take this
material you know from here I can play
pawn here to a5 few different moves that
you could play but I like pawn a5 again
kind of counter countering the move from
black on the Queen side and really just
forcing them to do something could also
come down here to be for threatening
this this night here on c3 you know I
can just respond with his Bishop here to
e3 putting a nother defender on the pawn
on d4 and he's not as worried about you
know the pawn here on b2 really depends
on how black goes about it again you
know if the knight comes to f6 your I
was just gonna play pawn here to e5 so
again from that a 6 move early on
there's not that many crazy lines
because again it's that the slot defense
is just really just locked down
that's very solid but it's more of a
slow methodical game and not these crazy
lines where you hope your opponent falls
into these different types of traps but
hopefully you guys enjoyed this
variation I had a lot of requests to
kind of go into deeper variations even
for some of the more common openings
like the car con so hopefully y'all
enjoyed and let me know what you think
and I'll see you on the next video
thanks for watching